okay well four people on the live stream
this is another episode in our insider's
view of software development and
software design and the topic today is
mathematical constants so let's get
going here so we have a function called
mathematical constant data and let me
pull up a documentation page that's been
created for it where is this this isn't
CVS this is not in um it's in the normal
documentation okay fine um okay and then
I will find out what this is the first I
think this is the first time I'm getting
to see this oh this is still not working
eleven three prototype build still not
working with doctor tools can we please
get that fixed okay it's basically the
equivalent to measurements give function
data but as the name says four constants
okay so let's let's start off with okay
so let's take a look at some recommend
some well here let's let's take a look
at the entities that are here oh wow all
kinds of wild things
what's a constant that is slightly
obscure okay Madelon sixty square
lattice constant don't we have a way to
compute that using like epstein Zeta
functions or something some of them can
be yeah it's a Muslim have closed forms
yes okay so let's take a look at that
guy there for example so if it does have
a closed form do we do we is there a why
is this taking forever if it does have a
closed form is there is there a property
that gives the closed form yes
if you
DCO DC yeah generally defining formula
would be what you want really yeah
that doesn't seem right defining formula
so I mean but some of these are sort of
derived mathematical constants so okay
all right so property so let's see if we
have a data set property here do we have
a data set proper I know actually that's
something I don't think I set up
property association will work though
okay but this should work
yes and why is it taking forever if it
isn't going to work
dad I can't tell you it hasn't been
taking for everyone I have run it on my
machine you know the title of the things
it's basically there's nothing to be
done
oh I see okay numerical approximation
how could it not have a numerical
approximation oh it does but it isn't
displayed here what's the story
let's try probably Association you guys
do exactly why doesn't that autocomplete
it's not certain the autocomplete yet
okay that is a very unimpressive
constant okay how can that not be I
could not even have a numerical value
yeah I don't know I'm writing it down
I tried a few this morning okay it's
just nice to kill well try something
obvious and make sure it works yeah okay
yeah try it try let's see that's
probably named off to my acquaintances
peter so now let's see whether his
constant works gets a sum of primes
thing okay that looks more encouraging
okay so we just constant wouldn't be
anywhere we don't have a digit right
what is this weird thing extension
backtick
so not calm yes okay so this you had
suggested that we introduce this context
pure mass which we are still working on
and it will be done in this new context
pure mass okay
is that a good idea I think yes because
we could associate it with once we have
it as a symbol we could associate
formatting and even some simple
numerical calculation okay but but then
that's kind of awful I mean but then
then we're effectively just introducing
a boatload of new symbols but isn't this
not what a VM Beck Tegan also picked
also also bigger context - yeah although
these are a little bit more direct
because they're just things were I mean
so numerical values then would just work
in these yes I know some of them decay
code is four digits or something like
this like okay but you know what to me I
would much prefer us to actually use
entities for this than to introduce I
mean if we have to for some internal
reason introduce a symbol and obscure
context fine but I mean to me this is
what should work in my view and what
about in so Stephen B could do this but
we have no precedent for such a thing
I'm aware okay okay
I mean I I it seems like a good idea to
me I mean okay so the question is the
precedent might be you know something
like this which we also haven't done any
of this kind that we haven't done what
are some other examples I think the most
obvious for me would be we have a caller
entity and we use a caller entity to
specify a color in which we should make
that work well I mean we have a lot of
mathy symbols where we used to and from
entity to go back and forth examples
yeah there's graphs
finite groups I believe coming back to
to the to the Cola example that you said
we should make it work the reason we
have made it work is that Carrick's is
totally inert and has no evaluation will
this means if we have it as an entity
the typeset would have to make the
entity calls which is very dangerous
with respect to damage okay let me think
about that for a second so the issue is
I see okay that's an interesting problem
right so you're a sue so this particular
thing here is making an entity call
right okay this one doesn't but there
are many did you because this is good to
color data so it has some local
information but if we have another color
okay so let's say we say color of the
IBM logo that kind of work I don't know
why is this why what an earth is this
what is that what did that just do I
mean it obviously returned this list of
things but what on earth is that
those are color entities but they
weren't properly wrapped in entity
wrappers I mean defected it returned the
list means it didn't find the
representation of also it did the
evaluation and alpha said oh I see what
you're saying
but do you think this will work I doubt
it okay so I was like entity where you
call our entities where there are
thousands of ten thousands of them and
she very what of type caller comma
entities
like this which took a couple seconds
for me because there are quite a few
10,000 of them
what enough are always what what do you
what there are are HTM a cause there are
couples hours and normalized Automobili
colas there are many many colors okay
but okay so so let me just be clear on
what you're saying yes so what you're
saying is this is one case in the case
of graphics where we don't get to do an
evaluation exactly like compared to this
Geographics where we do have non-trivial
evaluation attached so there we have
time to go out get something do
something
but with normal curve fix we don't have
a valuation so typesetting would have to
do the job and that's horrifying
aeneas on typesetting that's horrifying
I mean I think the only realistic way to
do that would be on input to evaluate on
input but that would be a change there
would be a big change is it obvious
whether we care I mean in other words
that would be something if we did that
we could also normalize some other
things
why don't we address that question with
Brett let's ask him whether whether he
thinks but still it would be able the
Asian rule for care fix because this
think on its own obviously cannot evil 8
no I agree why didn't that work that I
would have expected to work as well but
if you do two entity on on that yellow
box for men with you oh yeah front from
entity excuse me yeah I understand
I mean RGB color that's probably one of
this case Owens we are there it would be
straight forward to it it is Lewis okay
so what does that mean wide wide is from
entity I mean insofar as Fromme entity
works with Corona yellow is that because
we think Corona yellow just is that RGB
value whereas the Sonic
exactly exact basic basically from
entity is only gonna work on the eight
built-in constants eight or nine
whatever right because it can give an
exact representation whereas for the
sonic contact it can just give a certain
number of digits exactly which is an
argument for having n work on that
because then we can give it to a certain
number of digits and it can say oops I
ran out of digits if it has two we could
do this yeah well from entity could work
on anything that can be expressed as a
combination of built-ins you can use it
has to be an exact representation we
could we could hook that up to work the
design right now is to just only do if
you get a single symbol back desert
desert there's a second a little bit
more scary version what about you have
in functional identity of them something
that concerns clear plus constant equal
one do we really want to express it
through the entity that's it there's
another reason why we have this context
I do think it's what I don't see why not
I mean our symbolic computation system
is perfectly happy to take a picture of
a smiley face as a you know right I mean
it's perfectly happy to have if I have
like you know whatever it is if I can
get this image of an aardvark to work
there's absolutely nothing that says but
I can't use this I mean I think
everything will just work if I take the
image of the aardvark if I can get the
image of the aardvark there to the power
30 minus 1 and I want to factor that oh
how amusing ha of course that doesn't
work anymore because we now actually do
that that thing the square of the odd
words oh my gosh hmm interesting Wow
is there any way to prevent that I mean
I can I do graphics of the picture of
the aardvark
No how do I prevent the aardvark from a
vowel
sure you want our thing traffic's
because sure we did appropriate things
are okay this is definitely in the
category of let's see if it works now
okay okay that should definitely be in
the category of possible issues um
presumably for truth I don't know what
for I mean possibly easier for what
function well good question I mean it
might even sneak into something like
power I bet this is going to have broken
something I mean what an unintended
consequence throw that ugly picture that
aardvark we could have picked a more
exciting image but anyway the moment so
coming back so if we would say that the
entity son are constant represents the
sink itself then we must go this step
also for mathematical functions and then
we are there we didn't want to go at
something like that the entity sine
function of Pi represents the sink which
I thought we didn't want to go okay so
an analogous situation is with the
function repository where we have a
resource object representing a function
right and what we're going to do there
is it will look very much like this it
will look very much like so let's walk
through why we don't want the
mathematical function I mean so there so
what we're talking about is sine
function right yep
and that's no that just did that I don't
like you know because entity
mathematical function sine because this
is what in most cases or you can make to
entity
okay so your point is that of PI over
two just do nothing doesn't yeah because
there's no property called absolutely
that's a much worse problem yeah this
thing was not built to stand in for a
function and of course most entities of
the world like cities and countries it
doesn't make much sense right okay so
let's let's walk back to this this thing
here this is a problem um but we don't
introduce symbols in connection with
mathematical functions do we well in
connection with the entity type
mathematical functions do we for some
yes like for the ones that we have we
can of course use absolutely but what
about the ones we don't have we also we
need some simple to to write down an
identity how can we write down an
identity without typing a symbol and
they all right now in extension and we
were thinking moving them all into some
other bun like pure mess okay well let's
try a different possibility okay which
may be crazy okay what if this property
existed okay this may be crazy and
simply formatted as something which is
not quite a yellow box but something
similar to the yellow box so if this
thing shouldn't evaluate it stays as it
is yeah it stays as it is like that
every special one Popat eaten what sir
so simple it would be a very special
property a property that doesn't
evaluate yeah that's a little crazy yes
it does that needs a curly to avoid
evaluation
all right bad idea because there might
be other domains my symbol VD okay so we
walked through this whole question about
creating private symbols in the case of
the function repository
I don't think were you were you and that
let's go no I was not okay so this has
gone around multiple times and what we
eventually concluded and I wonder
whether we can
hey if if Erica's here could you see if
you can find Brad Ashby because in this
case it's easier like if you want a
certain function you're probably wanted
in Globus know but we don't want to do
it that way um let's see okay but let's
let's continue with this discussion so
that's an issue we're gonna have to
resolve but let's continue and look at
some of the other things that are here
okay preferably anymore okay so Oh
standard notation that by the way
whoever's on that they've got a bunch of
background noise would be really nice if
you muted Thanks okay using intervals
for lookup oh wow that's cool that's
really quite cool okay so let's see what
what's around so what about can I do a
nearest like what's the nearest one to
PI or something no we didn't we thought
about doing something but issues with
precision and things sort of prevented
clear design from coming through okay so
if I say mine a PI minus 0.5 to PI plus
0.5 oops
how can it have four
39 oh I see okay all right now how do I
get the numerical values of those
percent como numerical value
no it's an American estimation though
yeah numerical approximation or you
could do short numerical approximation
it's more convenient because often they
have a thousand digits if you asked for
actual numerical okay
dandy all right um
okay so this short let's take a look at
some of these properties like short okay
you already did one like that all right
what's probably show case this doesn't
show everything this just shows the ones
where there was maybe something to point
out or where there's only you know where
there's not a great amount of coverage
so I had to find a specific entity to
let you poke at if you want to look at
the basic ep example that gives you
maybe yeah it just gives your property
association oh let me just think about
this short numerical approximation thing
um let's see could could somebody please
track down Erik Broderick and ask him to
anybody who could do that I can fight
him you myth
um okay let's go back to this alright so
we've got this short numerical
approximation we're hearing heavy
breathing you might want to adjust your
microphone um all right let's just take
a look up through some of the other
things here theorems these are all in
text no we don't ever what could they be
nothing that's about the best they can
be
but we don't for example the formula
this the the name of the theorem is not
an entity yet not yet yeah soon
hopefully but this is nice this is
interesting how many do we have
not too many I think there's only about
a dozen that have theorems associated
with them we didn't spend too much
energy on this part is this stuff
sensible are these the only ones or
these no this is just random but so it
does that essentially everyone have a
have a traditional form yes but but not
everybody has a traditional form top
dish initely so then we fall back to do
typically Sivas indices is that a good
idea I mean is that conventional or
where would we see me conventional I
would say and why is this taking forever
sure seems really weird should be
instantaneous oh yeah it should not sure
I'm writing it I'm writing down all
these inputs that give us any trouble
and I'll check it out I'll save this if
you want but but um okay let's try
another ten that's a bad sign
I think that they're porting made no
done problem okay are you using the the
[Music]
caching infrastructure in a caching
infrastructure it's probably being used
behind the scene okay I don't think you
have to do anything active
you could probably want it clearer that
looks with one of these old-style pack
let's let's expose through the entity
framework presumably it is it's not all
tied back that it's fully entity valued
with a function on top okay okay fine
um I really need to find Brad here since
nobody else seems to be able to find him
I think I have to go on mute and go call
him
yeah I think I have seen this kind of
behavior after I uploaded some entity
value stuff well it's also
prototype build so if there any changes
or improvements going in might be
unlucky and catch them well the set
stream position stuff looks a little
foam debate for us yeah yeah although I
like I don't know what Weist
well the string split is just sort of a
fought down the chain from there so oh
but it actually returns something in the
end okay hello again
okay let's some take a look at this how
could there be a missing not available
here well that's another of the
madelung's and maybe there's just some
you know yeah these are pretty weird
notations and is that really a a
convincing notation for the hypercube
line picking constant whatever that
might be
yeah I think maybe a little toy isn't a
bit code for these it with traditional
form and it will look the way it looks
in a book it'll turn the brackets to
parents which is it's probably either
denoted that way or with the subscript
no that's nice
I meant the actual right-hand side of
that one yeah right well fine okay
fair enough okay what is parsing about
[Music]
hmm you can get them some control equal
good to end today from end today I spoke
we say this only works for the one where
we do have a symbol in system backtick
right and there is a bug a little bug
here that you'll see but I have it filed
um okay okay that's cute
it doesn't look very Gaussian to me but
it's amusing to claim that it's Gaussian
okay Kenshin's theorem okay oh they
really I think that's a probably look
normally with this I thought that I had
looked at what did I look at okay but
anyway they're very close to kenshin
that the continued fractions are very
close to satisfying you know to giving
the kenshin good geometric mean thingy
yeah Benford fairly close to Benford -
interesting okay those are all cool
all right let's go back here so the only
remaining issue it seems to me well a
couple of issues one is the short
numerical approximation thing you want
the property to be renamed or a
different result I'm not sure I mean
it's a little bit of a weird name and
you know nobody's going to readily I
mean that's the question of whether we
want to do this end thing the N seeing
can probably be done but of course we
need some approval form for this how
much of a hack is it does it actually
have to go inside and and so on
depends like if it's just the entity
then probably not then we can associate
it with entity but if it's somewhere
deep inside something then it has to go
in to end and you're not gonna ask that
you'll be able to use it as a symbolic
limited an integral or something are you
like right and so the point is if the
value well a symbolic limit as in it's
purely symbolic sure I mean I can take
one of these things so this is where it
gets a little confusing and I could take
one of these things here and I could
perfectly happily say you know this
apart from this error which I don't know
what it is but but um but that just
works fine so the only thing now that
doesn't work you would expect to work as
me saying n of this
you
I mean maybe you wouldn't expect to work
but it seems um you know because we can
do arithmetic on these things unlike for
the mathematical functions the entity
based mathematical functions where we
cannot I mean well that's for a very
specific weird reason you don't know how
many digits you can compute of one of
these things that's different from
things that are built-in where
presumably you know you can get ten
digits so you can get me but even
something much simpler like coming back
to the mathematical function comma sine
if you make this as a function of X and
you differentiate what do you expect to
happen in the ideal world yeah okay I
mean you could have some P listen yeah
right okay we really need to get hold of
Brad is if squeeze is here could you
please get Eric or get Brad directly yes
brats here well I don't know if I'm the
right Brad for this Brad Ashby no guys
thanks I'm calling Brad now
you
you
okay
okay so what else should we talk about
here let's look at the other properties
that you have um I was the property
collection
let's get rid of that ugly hot dog we
keep scrolling down maybe close the
section Aaron yeah hole properties okay
alternate names associated people what's
ok class is what classes do we have
mainly the field of mathematics so like
number theory constants and so forth and
then domain information like positive
complex rational try and transcendental
things like that okay how many of them
have re is links good question if you do
mathematical is it a lot or is it just a
few no it's I'd say actually I'd say
it's been a long time since I may be at
least another wonder humor yeah several
hundred yep okay sign why do we have
sign that was for convenience for
obviously mainly complex and there's
only a handful of complex so so that's
that's an issue where maybe we just put
a sign to do I mean it's a complex it
gives the direction in the complex
playing so well yeah you can find out if
it's positive or negative - yes sure but
so what but in the complex plane I don't
even know what SI capital it normalizes
to unit links yeah we're not locating
bash BA at any of it numbers okay can
you see then um so you can find Bob
Santana yeah correct
uncut actually actually sorry
what about Rick Hannigan
okay um so if you may say two plus five
I you see it better and just taking a
sink that's already the same okay it's
the unit vector yeah that's a pretty
obscure name for the unit vector I mean
it's just a feature of si GN I don't
know it it seems can be we can skip this
poverty seems really we can skip this
poverty and fold it into classes unless
there's some other property that takes
abs and you have to go inside in some
obscure way to reconstruct the sign like
how does continued fraction do that
explicit negative first number look what
bothers me about all of this is you know
all these operations like abs and so on
I you know I would expect the thing to
somehow just work you know if I pick up
this thing and I say you know fractional
part how do i compute the fractional
part obviously I can't just do this
right but so you want these things as
symbols you don't want them as entities
or you want them as symbols in addition
to entities I don't know what I want
because I just it will be just be good
to have I mean there's no easy way to
make that work and certainly we can't
make it work in the mathematical
functions case number one and number two
it's only to pronounced here because it
seems simple but in principle there are
some azimuth sumtin functions it might
well operate and also types of entities
like AR AR of a country could give the
area or something like this yes well
that's true but
okay so my if you would want my opinion
I mean I think that well one reason that
it looks ugly first of all is that that
we don't have the entity or excuse me we
don't have extension in the context path
so if we put these things you know it's
not desirable to do it because I'm less
praying we do not want to put it in the
context pub because then we're spraying
no you know of random symbols in there
but we let the user potentially not a
good idea it's not a good idea because
then then we're doing exactly what we
didn't want to do which is to have a lot
of random symbols you know in the system
we're okay having random entities like
you know the name of every movie and so
on in the system but we're not okay
having the names of movies as symbols
gadget um so constants are more mathy
than symbols I mean then release or
whatever so we're closer to being things
that we want to build in in some way all
right listen if we're not finding these
folks who know about the function
repository we should stop this meeting
um unless we find bass B or Rick but Bob
can come in is he gonna be here very
quickly because I've gotta leave in a
few minutes yeah yeah I he may not even
know about this
do you know but approximately the
solution yes we decided I know what the
end result is we decided that resource
objects will be that these things are
resource functions so it looks like you
know resource function of and then some
string okay that's the name of the
resource function and what will happen
is that this of arguments will evaluate
oh so it avoids to Portland Vista
context it doesn't solve it what do you
mean by avoids I mean in other words we
will never have a now unfortunately we
also discussed the possibility of
symbols coming in from these resource
functions and I don't recall what the
solution to that that we came up with
was
um I think now this year hi
we're talking about some stuff to do
with mathematical constant data and with
do you remember in the case of resource
functions what do we do if we want to
have a symbol that is the analog of a
resource function do you understand the
question yes well you can always just
set a symbol chooser resource function
no I understand up let's say we want to
introduce some random weird mathematical
constant you know squiggles constant
right what do we can we do that as a
symbol represented by some kind of
resource symbol construct you mean a
symbol that two terms that parameterize
this information it's not a symbol it's
not a symbol it's not a it's not an
actual symbol you're looking at the
screen here yes yes it's it's a thing
that is like one of these things these
are entities right and the question is
and those so what we're doing in the
case of resource function is we will
have a thing I don't know do you know
where there's a mock-up of this do you
have a mock-up of the what the visuals
for the resource function are supposed
to look like I think right in front of
me I can I can find one but but resource
function at the name function says it
expects an argument and once it's the
argument it knows what to do absolutely
assume you would have a resource
function that doesn't need an argument
it represents a a constant and you want
to know a lies so would end of resource
function without the additional argument
work no I don't think so but I think we
discussed the possibility of a resource
symbol also but I don't think we walk
through what that would actually mean
because a resource function will
evaluate when given an argument when not
given an argument it's just not
evaluating with the same reason that you
know doesn't evaluate right I understand
what you're talking about now I don't
think we've you may have discussed this
with Rick and he mentioned it to me but
I think we that you decided that it was
best for a different symbol not for
research function well and and another
thing Steven is that I wonder if
resource function is so general that you
know if I want that string to just say
sarnax constant it would be sort of nice
if I or maybe there's there's an example
that where it's not clear that it's a
constant from from this from the entity
blob I wonder if maybe what you want is
something that's just mathematical
constant open sore knack you know quote
unquote sore neck close and then that
object acts like the constant
enumeration and things but the entity
itself is just an entity like it's
always been of course there'd be
straightforward to do this with resource
data because you know but only it's not
straightforward to do it it's not
because it would return it would return
the promise the problem is you know
these constants don't end she said I'm
saying we only know them to some number
of digits right but it could evaluate to
an entity like thing but yeah what good
is that to us I understand so so I'm
what do we want it to evaluate to we
don't want it to evaluate but we want in
this particular case we want it to do
things like n but not to evaluate in
regular evaluation right so there are
there are special rules for how one of
these things is actually integrated into
language it has its own set of up values
well right right I mean so the thing
that we are discussing here so I mean
okay let's let's enumerate the
possibilities so one possibility is I
really don't like the solution of making
all of these symbols it really doesn't
seem right to me
at a symbolic level these entities are
fine they can be used in any symbolic
for any symbolic purpose what are the
properties that we want them to have we
want them to have four exam
though do they have the constant
properties so if we differentiate them
they'll be 0 yeah it seems like we would
want that yeah but but this will
automatically happen because there's no
expert seat dependent on anything like
any fine country different right ok fine
ok so what about you Mary q would be one
yeah what do we think the answer to that
should be I think it is No yeah I would
say false which it happens to be right
now ok so the only thing that we
actually think we want is n-not really
yes this might be the most obvious but
the most the most tricky one is if some
of them fulfill some functional
equations are excited constant exactly
as this how to express this identity or
they're even defined via simple
integrals or sums so then then you know
if this has the identity that this thing
you know sign of this thing equals
equals that thing squared or something
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
stating the identity like that well if
you hit it with n it's gonna give you
false probably know if you hit it with n
it's gonna do something reasonable which
is good what is wrong with this picture
no no I mean if you hit that whole
identity with n I'm a well why would it
give false value 8 well unless we make
and work with these things no there's
nothing wrong with this but thinking
this now one step Fazal to mathematical
functions stating sine square plus cos
squared equals 1 in entities this crazy
yeah exactly
ok umm why I thought this was gonna be a
really easy designer here the Heisenberg
cut ones are these entities and others
are the symbols well I won't keep
swimming up it does well where else does
it come up units
there's a go constants every time we
have a pretty computable language
version it becomes up like cities it
doesn't come up because we don't have a
computable version of a city also then
the entity I see what you're saying what
four units right now units are not
treated as entities units not but
physically constants like fine structure
constant VI is an entity yeah so what's
your point about that which one do we
want we want the one that is unit only
at the value the entity we have this
problem that something we want to be
able to get properties of it but we
ought to be able to use it directly in
computations like what what are cognac
table in the two rules
what are cornea it connects with exact
values yes
but we don't have a way to ask this
about the quantity version we only have
a way to ask this as a name property on
the entity version I understand I mean
so the trade-off is an entity can have a
bunch of properties hanging off it yes
but is not able to deal with functions
applied to it particularly coiffed exact
exactly whereas in the other case
functions are applied just fine but the
thing doesn't have properties hanging
opposite this is a very good summary yes
yeah what a mess um but we don't see it
the first time it's very pronounced in
this case in which case the constant
case yeah and it's nearly a number it it
it fulfills my typical meta theorem that
you know the only language with budget
design is a language which does nothing
the foxy loom yes exactly so modeled
after hogs theorem or um the okay
is it a fool's test to try to enumerate
every case in which it would act like a
quantity like a number well the problem
of Michael is I think in this particular
example of mathematical constants we
could in fact you know wire up n to do
the right thing do you agree with that
Michael and Erik but it would cause a
lot of unhappiness because calculating
some of them even if you haven't
algorithm might take forever or like
Jaden's constant there are four four
digits known and that's it how can there
be four digits known for a concrete
prefix free ba-ba-ba-ba-ba language I
think there are few digits for certain
models I thought it was uncomputable
maybe you can yeah I mean it's there
okay fine I mean I don't even know why
we have a constants that why does it
still do this that was supposed to been
fixed I think there are certain concrete
wheels and said in certain modern
languages have been a belated Aqaba
digits yeah I think that's right but
then why are we one earth interesting
that's very confused whatever is going
on there is very confused but your
session is the disco I already quit the
Titans constant is highly machine
dependent yes of course it is so it's
the whole thing probability of a
universal machine yeah depends which
well this is clearly crazy yes no
question this is completely crazy yes
yeah okay and I I would really think
it's almost comically wrong to have a
constant whose purpose in existence is
to be non computable and have it sit
there with a definite number now an
interesting question is do we want it to
be symbolic whoever's typing please mute
themselves sorry they an interesting
question is whether we want to include
non computable comp quantities and then
say missing you know for numerical value
say missing non computable see what I'm
saying yeah seems amusing at least I'm
not sure how useful it is but it well
it's useful in the sense that there's
metadata associated with it including
the very fact that it is non computable
plus there is a person and a year when
it was introduced there is a certain
meadow as you say right slate well I
think it's a I think it's interesting to
do that I think it's an interesting
example of our first foray into things
which are you know symbolic but non
computable if you understand what I'm
yeah yeah um if I time what would be
another example I mean another example
would be you know we could have a
function but it would be fairly stupid
saying you know halting time you know
where we basically just say I mean we
could imagine a function but this would
be very silly where we say holding time
of Turing machines such and such such
and such and often it would evaluate and
sometimes it would not there's no such
things they could convey certain
function or something like this that
basically says how many times to a
certain digit combination occurs in the
infinitely more something like this and
for a couple of things
who've never but for the majority of no
clue right well okay so look if we if
we're a numerating named mathematical
constants we should include the non
computable ones you know that that's
some okay which cuddly okay what's that
it does it's all for main sports Lily
doesn't solve our main problem although
it highlights another issue which is if
we have one that's not computable and
you hit it with n was it supposed to do
but but but the problem is already you
hit an identity with n comma handled and
there's no hope to ever succeed it to
just hang forever right
well is there also a problem that
hitting it with and you can't get an
exact value no most of these constants
don't have exact values most of these
constants have some algorithm to compute
them that may be incredibly inefficient
humph
well okay so what's your point Michael I
mean your point is just that that
regular I mean how many of them don't
make it to machine precision
oh really
oh no I I don't think it's that so how
many don't have so to be cheese
precision Zoe I thought you meant that
Zoe I was seeing you in the south and
digits
no definitely not I wasn't mean with
always yeah yeah okay so if most of them
make it to machine precision that's at
least you have a list some ire of um I
can send that I can send it to you in
the chat let me just get a notebook okay
well send it not in chat I'm finding
Edith okay I'm coming back to this I
really really don't like this okay this
really should be the entity but now the
question is is there any way if you've
got an expression that is full of so so
here's a question should from entity
it's not gonna be useful here it's not
gonna be useful I mean one possibility
okay so here's a bizarre idea for you
what if from entity had a second
argument does it already have a second
argument yes yeah what is it oh no to
end any argument so it to entity okay so
my suggestion from entity of an
expression comma and then the default
property that you are using to extract
you know to resolve that entity see what
I'm saying so in other words if we
allowed an expression here and so it
could be something like this for
instance yeah and then that thing said
short numerical value then you will be
able to resolve this I mean it's form
form entity the first argument would be
an expression or an entity's well I'm
saying that that we'd have to generalize
that to allowing an arbitrary expression
containing entities so I'm saying
although it's not going to be very
useful and it would even a toward would
sit there no I'm suggesting that from
entity I'm suggesting this that from
entity would would take an expression
like this and normally the default would
be something like identity in the second
argument okay identity is the right
thing yeah and that would simply turn it
into you know PI squared or whatever to
that but if that second argument here
was short numerical approximation yeah
then instead of returning PI squared it
would return the PI entity's short
numerical approximation squared I think
is the other domain or does it only make
sense for Constance I would I would
think that if
go to the trouble of to do this that you
would want to actually make that second
argument a list of rules and say
mathematical constant goes to short
numerical approximation calm yeah I mean
the other argument is what about entity
value because entity value after all
here entity value does allow a list
right of entities so why not allow
entity value to take an arbitrary
expression involving entities that seems
somewhat sensible as well are you
assuming that the property is the same
for all of them I don't think you can
make that some change no no no no we're
making that assumption because basically
what we're trying to do is have this be
the equivalent of doing N see I mean in
whatever but but but so my suggestion
here would be to make something like as
you this is not competitive crazy yeah
but you'd want an extension of this
where you can generalize a different
value for each entity that's crazy
that's pretty crazy okay but I don't
think what it gains us I don't see what
we answer it subverts any efficiency no
no look look the issue is how do you
take that expression and without three
lines of code you know replace Omega
constant by its numerical value slash
dot entity values s e entity goes to LA
okay okay I mean how do we take this
thing and you know do what is you know
basically the the moral equivalence of
applying end to it and I know understand
Bob's corn because this is specifically
for you know yes if you if you had in
here a city and a and a type of food and
things like that yes that's exactly what
I'm thinking it won't happen it won't
happen because those things are you know
they just don't they don't combine with
these in in this kind of way now you
might argue what if it was a table okay
so what if you had something which was a
you know an array of things where one
thing is a food and the other thing is
is a color or something I mean I think
that's in the category of you know what
terminus if some of them are entity
classes well what happens right now of
some of them are entity classes to
entity value so entity value what's an
example of an entity class let's say
number theory constants is that going to
work
I probably not first try do
transcendental constants I don't
understand why this bug I don't
understand why this bug with the with
what my thinking
yeah I don't understand why that's still
there okay so do you know the name of an
entity close algebraic constants so this
is mathematical constants that right
yeah oh but single singular and now yeah
I doesn't seem to know itself as an
entity class as an answer to class it is
yeah let me call constant data still
blue for you to I mean I
I build if you play enter the argument
string entities to this entity class I
mean right now it might be the trust the
forms not formatting yeah what sanity
list and you do lists no no you have to
apply either apply entity or call
entities yeah
no indeed huh okay I'm not really sure
that I just looked at that today okay
all right so what the possibilities
we've got on the table are doing
something like this okay okay
to nib is not like it but that makes
some sense
it seems the least crazy of the of the
things we have on the table right now
but it doesn't it doesn't solve the
problem how would you like this how
would you state an identity in this I'm
saying this is this is this is the way
you state the identity you just state it
using the thing as simple as a symbolic
object but why why do we even need a
symbol to state the identity why can't
we just invert it and solve for the
constant maybe as a transcendental root
object or whatever are there cases where
we can't do that no that's not the point
it's not for defining its stating
identity is obeyed yeah which what's
wrong with this way of doing it that
seems like a fine way of doing it
because I feel like if we stated this
way then people will write entity
mathematical function of sine squared
plus cosine squared and I really don't
think we want to go there that won't
work I agree
well what were the scroll down a couple
lines what were those alternate
representations or whatever well look at
the look at the horror of this well well
so they're we wouldn't actually need the
symbol we only need the symbol if say it
involves Boyd constant multiple times in
which multiple yeah if the you know if
it's some gold
you know if I squared plus five you know
yeah
well you could you could for instance
look at representation through other
constants right there I mean they're
there it's unavoidable right you're
always going to have the constant of
applying on though see so here's a good
example right
so you've got to have a representation
and this seems like exactly the kind of
representation we want however Michaels
issue is the slippery slope leads us
very quickly to mathematical functions
right yep at which point we have the
horror of the fact that the you know the
function applied to something you know
when we try and apply the function to an
argument it's gonna blow up not it's not
gonna blow up but large parts of the
system would have to be prepared when
they see an entity to somehow retrieve
some information about it and then
continue and like do we like what is
entity mathematical function sine Prime
is it cosine or is it entity cosine
Michael I mean the issue that we're
having here we're not saying the
fractional part of Boyde constant is
going to work right we're saying that's
just gonna sit there okay
so similarly with mathematical functions
it's perfectly okay if the mathematical
function if the entity based
mathematical function just behaves like
the function f the purely symbolic
function f okay right I I don't think
there's a problem with that the problem
is we have a syntactic problem because
the entity function when applied to an
argument will go crazy because it is
used to being fed property
specifications yes correct
but what I'm saying even this out the
the problem of playing the argument the
function derivative makes us over the
problem is the entity itself
why now what is derivative of one of
entity mathematical function cosine
what is it for app I mean for efforts
just if I say you know derivative of f
of X comma X right I get that
yeah and that thing is the dorota could
do have a themselves on mute um it's
just something like this it's just a
purely symbolic F there yes but
derivative of one of cosine evaluate
relative of 1/2 well you're saying that
if I do this thing if I do coast what do
you would know to point this out without
the X that's my point
this evil what does it do with an F that
does nothing it won't evaluate exactly
well that's fine so the it should just
do this it should do the thing as if it
doesn't evaluate because if you want it
to evaluate you would do you know entity
value and then you would say how to
evaluate it
I see so you would be fine if basically
derivative of one of entity mathematical
function cosine would not do anything
that's correct I'm I don't think there's
any choice because because so many of
the functions we're dealing with don't
have an explicit representation that
allows one to go anywhere with the ice
but then we still have as you said we
still have the second problem then this
argument that is a horrible problem I
mean in reality we don't have that
problem although it would require major
hackery to avoid it because in reality
the properties are all strings and
things there is no overlap in types so
to speak between the properties and an
actual function argument for a
mathematical function yes but this seems
this also a slippery slope slippery it's
hockey and I think it will crash and
burn
yeah I think so too ok so do we can use
the the the entity itself as its
representation of itself yes for the
function but what we can't do is to
apply that mathematical function to
anything which is kind of horrifying koi
hmm that's in distinction to a resource
function which okay so what we do is
opposite no no but but what we do in the
case of resource function is resource
object the corresponding resource object
is a thing that has metadata associated
with it but the resource function
expects to just eat function arguments
see what I'm saying yep so is there any
analog of that here that is you know we
have some freedom because the thing you
get from control equals yeah gosh we've
got the entity and the question is is
there any way of generating what is the
analog of the resource function versus
resource object dichotomy for resource
functions is there no there's no there's
no higher level so to speak yeah that's
one version of the entity there are kind
of two flavors no I understand a
resource function like resource data is
a kind of more active it's an active
slice that represents a particular
property of the resource object so the
question is whether here we can have
Shen's do we have a mathematical
function data roughly I fondled yeah
it's from entertain that equivalent it
is but it what the problem Bob the
problem is something different the
problem is look if we say oops wasn't
what I wanted at all um oh gosh this is
the problem I had before okay so if I
say entity I'm sure I have it somewhere
on the page here um there's a basic
function for my sense okay let's let's
pick a much more obscure function name a
more obscure function Q by no means okay
dandy okay so now here the problem is
we've got a bunch of weird background
noise by the way the problem here is
that if I say sine function of PI over 2
it's gonna say missing retrieval failure
because it doesn't know deep about the
PI over 2 why does it say retrieval
flavo failure why doesn't it say
property is missing that's a good
question oh yes Tony
if you stringify it it'll probably say
missing property as my guess
if this thing okay so that was a PI for
example yeah okay okay it is interesting
that those are different even slightly
encouraging for our current purposes I
mean it's a horrifying idea um and I'm
sure it will bite us in some other way
let's just think about it for a second
well let's see what it does if it would
bite us for every function that eats
things yeah well I know but but not none
of these that's really interesting but
but none of the mathematical functions
eat strings
that's not least as their as their
natural food so dismiss that's not there
they're their diet what does that call
for animals it's some what they
naturally eat I don't remember I don't
know um I mean you could always feed it
a string you know I could perfectly well
it just won't be very useful I could
feed sine a string just won't be very
useful alright so look what's on the
table is the possibility of possible
so that we could treat this as a
symbolic thing that we can make entity
value work with arbitrary composite
expressions and did we get an outcome
ETA and also we might yesterday might I
almost like your original suggestion of
using from entity even though it's a
little bit of an over loading of the
symbol then I mean from entity is not
nearly as useful in as integral to the
language as entity value by the way we
have a couple of comments from people
who are watching this live stream that
are kind of interesting
um one person asks these constants going
to be integrated into everything else
are they just a basic entity store
suppose I'm doing computations for an
arbitrary problem the result happens to
contain a mathematical constant will it
be represented using this mathematical
constant data so the answer is right now
I don't think we have any we do not
imagine that any built-in functions will
return things which are only in
mathematical constant data in fact I
don't think that's ever going to happen
because I think as soon as it is
something that we expect to return from
our internal algorithms it will have to
be some we will want it to be something
where we have properly integrated the
mathematical constant into the system
correct and so I don't think that but
but I mean these are really pretty much
well they're primarily things that are
just sort of constants where you're
going from the name to the properties
you're not going from the generate some
generative process process to the
constant right someone else is asking
what are examples of properties that are
not strings
well there's certainly things like dated
and so on but that's really not a not a
great I mean those are special cases um
about these dark holy files fair enough
i mean but dated appears in this yeah
yeah
I have to go guess the Madera shortcut
for something is right seeable um
chemical data and element data those are
entities those aren't properties yeah
what are entities non string symbolic
yeah well those are being updated anyway
but all right look I think the best
we've come up with here is the entity
value approach let's figure out how
horrified people are by that
but but the entity value approach we
don't need in sums it all what we need
is to where ever we currently have
expended extension backtick something we
stick in the entity itself sure that
that will be fine well actually I
wouldn't even bother in these cases for
the alternate definitions I wouldn't
bother here
yeah a deficit but but they for
what do we do for mathematical functions
where we do have arguments there the
other entity value does not really
really solve it what why how would it
solve it like like assume you have some
identity of some function G of X plus G
of I how does the entity Soulstice okay
so what I'm proposing is that this I
mean in by the way by the way by the way
by the way what you're doing here with
an actor in active versions um you know
you can perfectly well say I mean in
like this particular case you could say
something like that right yes but the
problem is when you when you activate it
it's just gonna go bonkers all hell
breaks loose right except if we put in
this hack to prevent it saying missing
retrieval failure and leave it symbolic
in this case I'm really afraid of that
hack I'm not sure if it can even work
honestly because assume you have earlier
defined X equal and then comes this
thing of a poverty well then you're
gonna get a stupid answer yes I mean
this is this is a deeply slippery slope
yeah there's no question that that I
mean but that's the specialness of
strings as properties is sort of an
established you know that's that's a
horror that's already happened yes
I mean this is yeah well let us let's
investigate whether this could work or
whether there's something that
absolutely kills it for some other
reason I suppose oh I don't know I don't
all right
what could we do with inactivation but
it's still pretty horrifying because
even if it's inactivated
it's not gonna help us because the
entity value has got to resolve it to
something
no actually yet if it's inactivated and
it's and the entity value resolves it to
something before it becomes activated
again we're in good shape but what would
you know I was thinking such an object
would be the return over of something
you ask do you have to Kupa normally
coefficient and you asked for functional
identities and assumed askew bonomi
square plus 2 binomials equally fine if
you had inactivated q binomial that's
the Woodworks I do Utley this would work
right okay
then walking through that if you did
entity values so let's say there was a
functional approximation for example to
the thing you could say entity value of
the think I'm a functional proximation
the function approximation would
substitute itself into the inactivated
area places then you would say
activation will be happy
I don't see a problem right now with
that but I mean the problem is that the
problem that I do see is the obvious
syntactic way to enter so if we put all
the identities for these like the Cubano
meals yeah with inactive it would work I
think that's a Chloe statement except is
it gonna prime someone to see that and
try and activate it right away without
doing this and I mean cuz it'll go
bonkers right so somehow we have to
describe this whole workflow in the Docs
and yeah I mean it's a bit horrifying I
almost feel like you know constants are
a special enough case that you know if
you wanted to avoid restructuring a lot
of things maybe just give these things
their own symbol mathematical constant
of open clothes I mean it's basically
just like an entity blob but at least
then people know okay this is a special
thing I think that's a bad idea
yeah because it's got all the other
attribute a matrix function which then
really has probably to work like then
you really expected to to calculate many
digits and all kinds of things yes which
we really cannot fulfill because nobody
can write okay so let's walk through
this one more time okay so the the thing
currently on the table is to generalize
entity value which i think is reasonably
sensible um that works so far as we know
with mathematical constants there are no
there are no obvious problems with that
correct
I don't see one I don't see no okay all
right now let's talk about that same
idea applied to mathematical functions
now what we're doing right now if I look
at Q binomial and I look at its you know
functional relations and things am I
going to see sort of put up symbols in
there
yes yeah okay it's a built in one but
for other ones yes
okay um okay well so the alternative
it's one refinement like if we would
have some special type setting for the
inactive of entity then I think I would
actually really like it okay because
like typically a mass formula you want
to see something reasonably compact you
know kinda you don't want to see a big
formal office with yellow boxes I feel
like it is too unusual too
unconventional okay so what so you're
suggesting that if we did this that we
could you know it reminds one of pork
somehow if one could get this extra
little piece and in then we'd go for it
but let's let's think that through okay
so what you're saying is that if we
could have inactive of a of this type of
entity at least yeah being something
that would show a shortened form yeah
well then people would at least not
think they knew how to type it in right
that has another advantage going for it
all right
but so what roughly would it be it would
be some kind of traditional form of the
thing with some box around it somehow
yeah exactly I think actually this might
be a good place to generalize because
what you could do do we have something
like labeled I don't use latex but
that's for graphics yeah so so what I'm
thinking of is like can I take an
arbitrary expression so I'll just call
it label label for now if I do label now
I can't do that label X so this this
does that I mean that's how that works
right but what what I want to do is I
want to have an expression just any old
expression in the first argument and the
second argument is say a string or
perhaps a row and and then
basically it's kind of the opposite of
an annotation it acts like the
expression except that it displays as a
purple box let's say you want something
like naked nice yeah yeah like a nice
something like that which we just built
okay yeah yeah I don't think I don't
think we need that mechanism I mean I
think that's a different mechanism like
if if if there would be a special
property for the entities that would say
how to represent myself has been
inactivated then we would have
everything together okay let's walk
through that why do we need that as
opposed to a thing which actually just
is the formatting of inactive of an
entity that's the same some that this
formatting must live and come from
though I understand what you're saying
well that's fine
because it might it might not be a
built-in and it might be a user entity
an entity store that's why it needs
somehow be a part Justin that's
interesting yeah that's interesting okay
um do we have a universal like
inactivated entity format well I mean
look it would be what it basically is is
is the display names right of things
like common name exactly it's a flavor
of this yes right so what it would be is
you know inactive display or something
like that right
inactive display form but it would be
more complicated because like if you're
single mathematically functions they are
subscript superscript right I mean so I
can say an active display form and it's
an arbitrary box structure exactly okay
I think we got a solution here
I like this yeah actually
and I would suggest that I still kind of
like the boxiness of an entity like
thing like you know what I mean like I
don't know if just having a say say just
a box you know how do I tell that this
is specifically something representing
an entity maybe maybe we should color it
or something you know
sure like like units physical quantities
can if it is a background or something
like right very similar to one of those
but but I think what's interesting here
is that we've essentially the solution
here is analogous to the solution
between a resource object and resource
function namely the entity here is the
resource object with has all its
properties associated with it and what
we've done is we've said that inactive
is the kind of semi hacky thing that is
the corresponds to the resource function
yeah I like it like if we go into the
direction if you think on say
mathematical structures upstart
mathematical structures there's also
observe that we cannot calculate
anything with them we still want them as
entities because they have properties
and we want to fry down classical
traditional math entities in there all
right yes this is nice because anyway
those things are full of an activation
because we don't actually want exactly
we don't want it active to be anyway
because respect to plus and even such
stuff although we do expect canonical
you know we do expect double equals to
work because these things have been if
they are canonicalized
then we expect identity testing to work
a quality testing to work which it will
it should all right very good we need to
figure out I think well I think we're
done here we cook good a good solution
to this yeah okay okay one last little
piece though with the value thing where
you have the third argument second
argument there's no third argument you
mean that the first argument is not
bitter expression containing ended yes
yes that one oh yeah we need to explore
that
separating okay that's a different story
it sounds I think probably if he wanted
me one probably the second argument an
association like this this entity type
to this with this entity type yes yes
that's that was the point I was that's
exactly what I was gonna say Michael so
okay sounds good all right okay thank
you very much thank you see you bye